how do banks actually create money
hundreds of years ago Banks stored gold
for investors but they realized it was
unlikely everyone would claim their goal
back at the same time
so they began to learn some of these
gold deposits out to other people this
made money for the bank through interest
and helped power the economy by allowing
idle deposits to fuel new business and
trade
as time went on the bank started issuing
banknotes or ious rather than physically
giving out gold and these ious started
being traded in the economy this meant
the amount of money in circulation was
much larger than the value of the gold
held by the Banks so the bank's lending
had in effect created new money nowadays
most money is digital when the bank
makes a loan it credits a new asset on
its balance sheet and credits the
borrower's account with new funds which
creates a new deposit every time the
bank makes a new loan it creates new
money this is known as fractional
Reserve Banking and its fundamental
principles have been the same for
centuries